[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning some
health professionals say addiction to
anti-anxiety medication is a growing
epidemic 91 million prescriptions were
written for anti-anxiety drugs like
xanax last year they're commonly
prescribed for anxiety panic disorders
and insomnia roughly one in eight
american adults use them xanax is part
of a class of anti-anxiety drugs
commonly referred to as benzos and is
one of the most prescribed psychiatric
drugs in the united states but some
users can experience brutal withdrawal
symptoms when they try to quit in a new
episode of 60 minutes plus correspondent
seth doan spoke with one young woman
about her struggle with
addiction we met grace on day 240 of a
grueling process of trying to wean
herself off an anti-anxiety drug she was
taking on doctors orders how is it to
still have to take it it's
honestly
miserable um it's a little bit well no
it's definitely a mind game because i
want nothing to do with this yet
in order to function and get off of it i
have to keep taking it she was 16 when a
psychiatrist gave her a typical starter
dose of xanax of 0.25 milligrams after
she says she was physically and sexually
assaulted
at her highest dose she told us she was
prescribed up to 24 times that amount 6
milligrams did your doctor express any
concerns about upping the dose
no
never did your doctor talk to you about
problems getting addicted
never
what did your doctor say she just wrote
it to me and gave it to me and you
thought what
this doctor's trying to help me because
my anxiety disorder is getting so much
worse
so i must need what she's giving me
grace told us her doctor also never
warned her about the challenges of
coming off the drug what's known as
tapering
what does it feel like to taper it's
night sweats night terrors
massive rebound panic attacks
i set a timer of 15 minutes to tell
myself let's survive this 15 minutes and
then it'll be done and then when the 15
minutes is up
i hope to god it's
done but it's usually not um
so i usually reset that timer
and 60 minutes plus correspondent seth
doan joins us now seth good morning
good morning to you um we just heard
some of the challenges from grace there
what have you heard from the makers of
xanax
we spoke with beatrice which is they are
the makers of xanax they told us that
this is a drug that is a treatment
option has been a proven safe and
effective has worked for millions of
patients they say that they're always
updating
the label the warning label as guidance
evolves and they say it's imperative for
medical professionals to work within not
only during the course of this but also
to identify the risks before they are
prescribed that's one of the things that
a lot from people who are going through
this process like grace who you see in
that clip
she said i just was never warned i had
no idea that this would become something
that i would feel so addicted to and
then have such difficulty tapering
coming off of it you know even just
talking about it before we heard from
grace there were it seemed like there
were parallels to the opioid crisis and
one doctor does compare it to that what
are some of the similarities between
them
absolutely we spoke with dr
anna lemke who's in charge of addiction
medicine at stanford and she told us
that she feels that she was one of the
early warning doctors out there who were
testifying and such worrying about this
warning about this opioid crisis and she
said she sees a lot of parallels and
even though the the highest number of
prescriptions for benzos
were back in 2013 and there has been a
slight downward trend she says they saw
that also in the opioid epidemic where
doctors prescribe this and maybe there's
an awareness of some of the risks those
prescriptions might go down a bit but
you have
just this chronic relapsing uh issue
where people are then replacing the
drugs with something else we spoke with
little zan lil xan is a is a rapper zan
is short for xanax and he
taking 50 times the initial starter dose
which of course he could not get
so he said
in what was given by his doctor with
what he could find from dealer street
all right seth thank you very much you
can watch 60 minutes plus report right
now on the viacom cbs streaming service
paramount plus